de l'analyse au roman dans tous ses
livres marie cardinal mail
autobiographie et fiction amour amour
qui vient de sortir n'échappe pas à la
règle
l'écrivain ne reparle de son algérie
natale aujourd'hui elle partage son
temps entre le vaucluse et le canada
mais c'est à paris que dominique poncet
benoît véran l'ont rencontré quelques
instants partagés
j'ai jamais écrit pour avoir du succès
elle n'a peut-être jamais écrit pour
avoir du succès mais le succès là au
moins libéré d'une charge celle de
professeur de philosophie car depuis
près de 40 ans marie cardinal a cette
chance accordée à peu d'écrivains celle
de vivre de sa plume
je suis né en 61 quand j'ai commencé mon
analyse c'est comme ça aussi que j'ai
commencé à écrire parce que trois
séances par semaine ce n'était pas
suffisant et et alors j'ai commencé à
écrire alors que je n'avais jamais pensé
que je pouvais écrire jamais mais quand
elle a commencé à y penser
elle n'a plus jamais cessé de jeter des
mots sur le papier avec cette sincérité
cette liberté de ton et cette franchise
qui la caractérise
marie écrit tout le temps presque
compulsivement pour obtenir cette vérité
dont on ne sait jamais si elle est
vraiment sienne c'est difficile
d'expliquer ce qui est faux et ce qui
est vrai surtout mes livres ont toujours
l'air d'être très autobiographique et au
fond ils le sont peut être mencière oui
c'est ça alors
je je je brode je prends des trucs que
j'ai co que j'ai que j'ai vécues ou coup
j'ai vu puis puis met dans la bouche
d'une personne qui est moi mais c'est
sûrement souvent par mois est ce que ça
vous énerve quand on parle de
littérature féminine oui ça m'énerve
parce que je vois pas qui est
l'initateur féminines comme moi je me
sens pas une femme que j'écris champ je
sens que je suis vivant voir c'est si ça
je vis il y a longtemps que marie la
méditerranéenne a dû quitté son algérie
natale c'est algérie qu'elle revendique
sans cesse dans ses livres et dont elle
vient parfois nostalgique et gourmande
retrouvez les senteurs à la mosquée de
paris paris pourtant elle ne vient plus
guère sauf pour les inévitables séance
de dédicaces de creuser la tête pour les
polynésiens en jeu mais toujours la même
chose je suis nulle pour les dédicaces
jeu je suis nul je mets avec ma
sympathie en témoignage d'amitié
je suis nul je suis nul